e
Herkese merhabalar ben Merve Göker bugün
buraya size bir tatlı tarifi vermeye
geldim Aslında vereceğim tarihte
kullanacağımız malzemeler hepinizin
evinde bulabileceği malzemeler fakat ana
malzememiz ve bolca kullanmamız gereken
malzeme Aslında hepimizin içinde bolca
olan fakat nasıl kullanmasını
bilmediğimiz ve belki de bir kere
kullanınca artık az geçebileceğimiz
malzememiz olacak bak Öncelikle un
ekliyoruz kullanmamız gereken
malzemelerimizi süt var 2 3 adet yumurta
kullanıyoruz ve ana malzememiz asla
kısma dımız ve bolca kullanmamız gereken
malzememiz hayallerimiz var Eğer
Hazırsanız şimdi bu tarifi nasıl
yapacağımız kısmına geçebilirim bu Eğer
kalbini koymazsam tarifler tutmaz
demişti olunca ben ünlü gazeteci ve
yazar gelince olsun ne demek istediğini
kalbimden büyük bir parça ve malzemeden
hiç kızmadım hayallerimle oluşturduğum
tatlılar ile ve bu sapları tadan
insanlardan aldığım onlarca olumlu geri
dönüş ile çok daha iyi algılıyorum Bense
Bugün beni bu etkileyen sözden yola
çıktım Bunu kullandım Siz hızlandım
tereyağı kullandım Gözlerimi kapattım
kendime baktım ve hayal ettim ve
hayallerimi katarak bir sürü tatlılar
yaptım kimi zaman tariflerim de işte
çikolatalı yerine meyveli tatlılar
yaptım kimi zaman tariflerim yanlış oldu
fazla pişirdim çok pişirdim ama
değişmeyen malzemem Hayallerim her zaman
reçetemi na na malzemesi ydi Abi ben
bugün bu konuşmaya hazırlanırken ve
Aslında
Gençliğim ve hayat boyunca birçok TED
konuşması dinledim her biri
hayallerimizin peşinde koşmaktan
içimizdeki potansiyeli keşfetmekten ve
kendimizi sevmek ile ilgiliydi kimi
zaman ne demek istediklerini anlamadım
belki birazcık kesim küçüktü ve Anlamak
istemedim o dönemler hayatı Bu kadar
ciddiye almamayı tercih ediyordum Ee
fakat şimdi ilk kez size bu konuşmayı
yaparken hissettiğim konforla ve o tatlı
heyecanla birlikte ilk kez 28 yaşında
söylenen bu sözleri Kıymetini ve Aslında
hayatın karmaşık olmayan kalple ve
tutkularımız lav ve en önemlisi
dişleyerek yaratıcısı olduğumuz bir yer
olduğunu anlıyorum Benim dişlerim ve
gözlerimi kapadığımda hayal ederek var
ettiğim yer bugün sahip olduğum
girişimim canım isim mutfağı o
mutfağının en güzel ürünü ise
Ben her zaman hayal ederek ve tarifinden
Asla ödün vermedim Hayallerim katarak
oluşturdum kurabiyeleri Mim Aslında
bugün burada yapacağım konuşma kadın
girişimcilik hikâyesinden veya bir
başarı hikâyesinden çok Çünkü henüz
başarılı değilim başarısız da değilim
Sadece başarıya giden bu yolda keyifle
ve büyük bir emekle ilerliyorum şu
maslıne da bir var etme hikâyesidir
bugün mu ha reddin çoğu şeyin Aslında
kalpten bir soyuttan bir görünmeyenden
hayallerden ve kalpten
ve en önemlisi bunlardan kaynaklandığını
unutmayarak oluşturdum girişimin
hikâyesidir Aslında ben bugün burada iyi
oldum hak konular hakkında konuşmak için
geldim İyi olduğum konu ise tatlı yapmak
mutfakta vakit geçirmek ve pasta yapmak
belki size konuşmalarımız bazen soyut
gelebilir Çünkü ben hep yaşamak gibi ama
bazı şeyleri yaşıyor gibi anlatınca bir
süre sonra gerçekten yaşadığına inanırım
yaşadım da inanarak ve gülümseyerek
anlatırım Çünkü anlatırken yarattığımız
enerjinin Aslında yaratıcı biri olduğuna
inanırım her zaman inanırım ve gereğini
yaparım Gereğini yapmak nedir
inandığımız yolda istediğimiz şeyin
peşinde koşmak Emek vermek ve inanmaktır
Aslında benim bütün hikayem bil var etme
üzerine
bir hayal etme üzerine kurdum
girişimimiz hikâyesidir bunun
tohumlarını attığım gerisi üniversitedir
bir liseden bahsetmiyorum Çünkü lise
Aslında
girişiminin veya hayal ettiğim herşeyin
başladığı yer değil de bugün bu
konuşmayı yapan Merve'nin benim
kişiliğimin oluştuğu yer İnanılmaz
eğlendiğim İnanılmaz bir arkadaşlıklar
kurdum ve bugün bu yolda Sen bana hangi
rotada olmamı Nerede olmamı söyleyen
öğreticilerin olduğu bir yer ve hiçbir
zaman unutmayacağım bir yer olarak
kalbimde benim için fakat kariyer yoluma
baktığım zaman
Aslında üniversitede ilkk hikayemin
başladığı yer tohumlarının ekildiği yer
olarak
başlayabilirim
Ben de herkes gibi küçükken Aslında
Astronot olmak istiyordum bir dönem
Öğretmen olmak istedim Bir de ben moda
tasarımcısı olmak istedim yüzmeye
gidiyordum sporcu olmak istedim müzik
aleti çaldım Müzisyen olmak istedim
birçok farklı kimliğe büründü miyim
resim yapıyordum sanatçı olmak istedim
ama her zaman sözcüklerin ortak
noktasına baktığımız zaman Aslında tonda
bir kenara bırakırsak her zaman yaratıcı
olmayı düşledim Çünkü Hayal etmeyi çok
seviyorum Hala çok seviyorum ve öneririm
hayal ederek bir şeyler var etmenin
kıymetini daha çok küçük ya O da
farkındaydım diyebilirim iç mimarlık
Bölümü'nü kazandım ay oldu emek verdim
istediğimde bölümde iç mimar oldum fakat
artık arkadaşlarım üniversitede
seçtikleri bölüm için ne yapabilirim
diye düşünürken de o yolda stajlar
yaparken ben hala üniversitede Aslında
potansiyelini keşfetme macerasında
yaydım derdindeyim diyebilirim mutsuz
değildim Fakat bu istediğim şeyin iç
mimarlık olup olmadığından Emin değildim
ama boş durmadım Her zaman gözlerimi
kapadım ilerde kendimi nerede görmek
istediğimi hayal ettim nasıl bir meslek
sahibi olmak istediğimi nasıl bir aile
kurmak istediğimin gün bir günümün nasıl
geçmesini istediği her zaman hayal ettim
ve üniversitedeyken bile aslında çok
farklı kurslara gittim çok farklı
dersler aldım şu moku duğum bölümü
seviyorum fakat aramız çok iyi değildi
desem daha doğru olur fakat buna rağmen
notlarıma bakarak konuşun çok başarılı
bir öğrenciydim ve bölüm değiştirme
kararı aldım işletme mi okusam hukuk
fakültesine mi gitsem Çünkü puanın
Aslında yetiyordu bölüm değiştirmeye
birçok alanda kaybolmuş gibiydi Fakat o
dönemki şartlar ve bazı bölüm değiştirme
cesaretine sahip olmayışından dolayı iç
mimarlık bölümünü bitirdim fakat dediğim
gibi her zaman dişleme ve hayal etmeye
devam ediyordum ve o zamanlar düşlediğim
yer yurt dışıydı
Aslında yurtdışı maceram tamamıyla
zihnimde Hayal kurarak başladı
diyebilirim Çünkü okullara ailemden
sevdiklerimden ve arkadaşlarımdan
sakladığım ve gizli olarak yaptım burs
başvurularıyla başladı birçok yarışmaya
katıldım ve dediğim gibi Aslında bu
mutfağın işim kurabiyelerin den
bahsediyorum ama aslında kalbimde o
zamanlar yapmak istediğim şey
girişimcilik timus Ben olsam bile
kendimi birşeyler yaratmak ve var etmek
ve bunlar hakkında hep konuşmak
istiyordum hep başarılı olacağını hayal
ettim hep insanlara ilham verdiğimi
hayal ettim ve gastronomi bunun için en
keyif aldığım alandı
ve Milano'da biziz Design bölümü adı
altında Türkçe çevirmem gerekirse iş
tasarımı Daha doğrusu girişimcilik adı
altında Biz Master burslu kazandım ve
bir hafta içinde Konfor alanından çıkıp
isimden istifa edip çoğu zorlukla bu
isim Maddi manevi boyutu Zorlu ile
birlikte milanlı uçtum ve Aslında benim
kırılma noktam hayallerimi attım adım
Milano'da başlamış oldum orada kendi
okulda birçok
projeleri mi Aslında gıda projeleri
yaptım girişimcilik ve gastronomi bir
araya getirdim ve hayal ettim Ne
yapabilirim nerede olmak istiyorum diye
buradan Amin ama dolma ve Milano'da da
astronomi alanında bir Türk olarak var
olmak istiyordum fakat nasıl
başlayabilirim bilmiyorum Sadece
Milano'da olan iki tane Hindistan'da ev
arkadaşımla paylaştığımı bir evime gene
paylaşımlı olan bir mutfağın kısıtlı Bir
öğrenci bütçem bu öğrenci bitti mi
Sadece orada Gıda ve birkaç ihtiyacını
karşılamaya sosyalleşmeye yettiği bir
bütçe ile mücadele ederek o küçücük
mutfakta kısıtlı alalım ve kısıtlı süre
ile kalabalık bir evde tatlılar
pişirmeye başladım Daha İhtiyacım olan
tek şeyin hayal etmek bir sıfatıyla ve
bir fırın olduğunu fark ettim
malzemeleri alıyordum evdeki
arkadaşlarıma taktırıyorum çok fazla
İtalyan arkadaşım vardı Onlar toplarım
atmaya başladı ve Aslında ilk Hayalimin
gerçekleştiği yer
İtalya'da çok lokal bir mutfak
dergisinde bir ilk Türk olarak var olmam
oldu o mutfaktan çıkan bir o zaman orada
olan İtalyan lokal arkadaşlarım
tarafından desteklenmesi sonucu Dergiye
çıkmasıyla birlikte bir Türk olarak San
Sebastian cheesecake tarifi verdim ve
orada attığım bunun gıcık adım bu
küçücük adım bugün buraya beni konuşmacı
olarak ve belki de çok genç bir kadın
girişimci olarak getirdi diyebilirim
daha sonra orada bulunma isteğim ve bu
alanda ilerleme isteğim daha da
hareketlendi ve ve orada birçok hastane
ile ve dondurmacı ile konuşmamla orada
staj istemem L sadece değil aslında
getir götür işi yapacak birini arıyor
musunuz dememle devam etti çok az
İtalyanca bilgim vardı yeterli
olmadığını söylediler kendi kendime
İtalyanca öğrendim çünkü pandemi
dönemiydi ve bütün kurslar kapalıydı
fakat italyancanın da önüme geçen şey
bahsettiğim gibi Panda mide ve birçok
pastaneden Aslında dışarı at o maskeli
bir şekilde bile onlara yardımcı olmamın
mümkün olmadığını söylediler Zaten çoğu
yer bir süre sonra kapandı ve yurt
dışında bir gastronomi alanında var olma
Hikayem orada bitti ama Hayallerim ve
zihnimde asla bitmedi kendime bir
dondurma makinesi satın aldım
biriktirdiğim bir paramla çok da cüzi
bir rakama almıştım
İtalyan arkadaşlarımın desteği ile ve
ailemi aradım okulumuzda bitmesine yakın
bir dönemde
dondurma üreticisi olmak istediğime
karar verdim ya bunu Türkiye'de yapmak
istediğim onlara söyledim onlardan iç
mimarlığı neden yapmak istemedim ve dair
sorular sorsalarda bir noktada beni
desteklediler ve ben Türkiye'ye geri
dönüş yaptım fakat üzücü olan ve sansız
olduğumu kısım bu aldığım dondurma
makinesi ile Türkiye'ye geri dönemedim
fakat içinde her zaman bir yerden
başlamak bir şeyler yapmak üretmek
yaratmak gülüşü vardı ve Ne hayal ettim
orada öğrendiğim türk-italyan kültürü ve
her zaman içinde olan var ettiği mesaj
attım Türk kültürüyle bir sakın
eslesmeler yaptım ve kendimi tamamiyle
kendi aile ev mutfağında ürettiğim
tamamıyla profesyonel olmayan bozuk bir
ev fırıncıyla görür ettim kurabiye marka
mı kurdum elimi yaktım Eğer bugün hala
izleri kalıcı bir şekilde var Ve hiç
geçmeyecek şekilde
bugün geldiği noktayı bana hatırlatan
izler ettim ve kurabiye üretmeye
başladım İtalya'da öğrendiğim arada
tarifleri uyguladığım yeni tarifler
keşfettim hala pandomimi dönemi olduğu
için Türkiye'de kurslar alamadım
tamamiyle kendi öğrendiklerim L Kendimi
geliştirdim Evet Türkiye'de birçok
Aslında etkinlikte var oldum hepsine
mail attım Çok güzel geri dönüşler aldım
birçok etkinlikte çok küçük metre bu
patlar açtım gözlerimi kapattığımda
ustadları önünde binlerce insan hayal
ettim gözlerimi açtığımda sandığımın
önünde kuyruklar vardı bunu tamamıyla
Hayal etmemiz ve düşüncelerimle ortaya
çıkarmanın bir sonucu olarak sizlere
anlatmak istiyorum Çünkü o dönemlerde
belki insanlara kurabiyeler dediğim
ediyordum kurabiye satışı yapıyordum
fakat herkese inanın size anlattığım
gibi yapmak istediğim şeylerden yaptığım
şeylerden ve bugün markanın Buraya nasıl
geldiğinden bahsettim ve Bence İnsanlar
bir kurabiye satmaktan çok bu hikaye de
var olmak istediler ve Aslında biz
hepimiz bir hikaye var ettik diyebilirim
bu ve bu hikayenin ve hayal etmenin
sonucu olarak bugün İzmir Çeşme'de bir
pastane açıyorum
Aslında Tamam mi yegene hayal ederek ve
bir sonraki adımda kendimi nerede görmek
istiyorum diye kendime sorular sorarak
Tabii ki ailemin ve yakınlarının desteği
ile bir pastane açıyor oluyorum Bugün
sadece acaba şöyle olsa ismi nasıl olsa
oluşu renkleri kullansak böyle olsa
diyez elimde hayal ettiğim bana destek
olan arkadaşlarım ve ailemle çıktığı bu
yolda bugün burada size işimden bahsede
Biliyorum size bahsettiğim gibi ürünleri
küçücük bir ev mutfağında profesyonel
olmayan arızalı bir fırında pişirmek
sonucu elimde bugün hala izleri olan bu
yaralar bugün bana bu işin nasıl
başladığımı hatırlatıp Hayallerimi en
güzel anılarımı nasıl çevirdiğini
anlatıyor o
unutmamalıyız ki her yeni girişim Her
yeni eylemin ana malzemesi Ancak onu
harekete geçiren heves kadar sonsuz ve
canlı olur Ben bugün burada size bir
başarı hikayesi anlatmıyorum bir
yolculuk anlatıyorum Umarım bir gün bir
yerlerde gene ilham edecek konuşmalar
yapıyor olurum ve bu sefer size bir
yoldan ve bu yolun başarıya nasıl
çıktığından bahsediyor olurum o Umarım
bu konuşma ile Herkesin kendi Hayat
reçetelerine bir Susam hayallerini ve
kalbinden bolca sevgilerini eklediği
Ninja tarifleri olur herkese kucak
dolusu sevgiler diliyorum